the dispute between the United States
and China is about much more than trade
for everything from blockbuster films to
lunar exploration from semiconductors to
submarines in every domain there now
rivals superpower relations of soured
America thinks that China is stealing
secrets stealing its way to dominance
and then it looks at Chinese behavior in
the South China Sea and and bullying
countries like Canada and Sweden and it
thinks that China is beginning to
challenge global norms but it looks very
different from Beijing from its point of
view America is trying to block its
entirely justified rise everyone else it
seems like the beginnings of a new kind
of Cold War a cold war that everybody
could lose of course America is fought a
cold war before with a Soviet Union and
it won so why not just do the same thing
again and cut China off isolated
economically well it's a bit more
complicated than that in the late 1980s
the United States and the Soviet Union
did about two billion dollars worth of
trade a year today China United States
do two billion dollars worth of trade a
day and then there are the allies who
helped America in the first Cold War
with the Soviet Union
well they do a lot of business with
China they want to be able to trade with
it it would cost them a lot to stop so
to persuade them that they must choose
security over their own prosperity would
be very hard indeed
the first thing is that the United
States needs to build on its strengths
these are often institutions and
alliances the institutions that the
United States built after the Second
World War the second thing the United
States needs to do is to shore up its
defenses and that means defending itself
militarily through cyber and space but
also defending its technology but the
third thing is that the United States
and China need to learn how to live
together in a low trust world China
America don't have to agree about
everything in order to agree that they
should live by some global norms so you
need to find ways to build trust over
North Korea say over rules for cyber war
or space warmth China is challenging
America in every domain business and the
profit motive and no longer enough to
keep this relationship together what the
relationship desperately needs is the
building of trust in the building of
rules unfortunately just now both sides
see rules are something to break